ونحييكم من جديد نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه التركيه يتردد صداها
اقليميا بلوحه دوليا فتركيا من دول مجموعه
العشرين لديها ثاني اكبر قوه عسكريه في
حلفانات وبالاضافه الى دورها الامني بين
البحرين الابيض المتوسط والاسود عوامل يرى
محللون انها دفعت انقره لتغيير سياستها
تجاه الولايه المتحده والناتو بل وحتى
الاتحاد الاوروبي انقره متهمه باستغلال
موقعها الجوستراتيجي ودورها في كثير من
الملفات والاتفاقيات الامنيه في المنطقه
الى جانب توظيف ملف اللاجئين ضد اوروبا
الذي يعتبر من ابرز الملفات التي يمكن
لاوروبا ان تتخلى عن تركيا فيه وبدات
السنوات الاخيره الماضيه لافته بتلويح
اردوغان بان اي دوله تعد تركيا ستكون هي
الخاسره تحديدا بعد ان حصلته اوروبا
سياسيا بصراما اثر ما وصف بتجاوزاته
اتفاقيات البحريه في شرق المتوسط فتاه
الوقت تتمثل العلاقات التركيه الامريكيه
بانها تكاد ان تصل الى حد القطيعه اثراء
انتقاد اردوغان بشده موقفه واشنطن الذي
رفض تركيا عمليه عسكريه في الشمال السوري
ماذا دفعه لعرقله انضمام فنلندا والسويد
الى حلفانات ونكايه بواشنطن التي تؤيد هذا
الانضمام بقوه وفيما بعد محاوله لترميم
تلك العلاقات مع اوروبا وامريكا طرح
اردوغان نفسه كوسيط في الصراع الروسي
الاوكراني بطريقه فسرت على انها ارتباط او
ربطها البعض بانها ترويج لنفسه كقائد
عالمي
نتابع هذا الموضوع نعود من جديد الى
ضيوفنا من اسطنبول زاهد جاريس تحرير طه
عوده اوغلو الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كما
ينضم لنا كذلك من باريس دكتور محمد سيف
الدين الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور
اسمح لي ان ابدا معك من باريس دكتور هل
هذه المتابعه الدوليه خاصه لهذه
الانتخابات التركيه
متعلقه او مرتبطه بمخاوف من ان تغير تركيا
من سياستها وما الملفات الابرز التي عين
الغرب عليها فيما يخص هذه الانتخابات
نعم الاهتمام الغربي بدايه بالانتخابات
التركيه ليس نابعا من احتمال تغيير تركيا
لسياساتها هو نابع من استمرار تركيا بهذه
السياسات تركيا في الاونه الاخيره مارست
سياسه مستقله نوعا ما عن تحالف الغربي وعن
الناتو التي هي جزء منه وهي الان تمارس
هذا الدور في محيطها وتشرع في محاولات
للعب دور الوساطه في ازمات دوليه متعدده
وتشبك شركات مع دول يعني تعادل الغرب
وتتنافس مع الغرب اقتصاديا وسياسيا وجيو
سياسيا كروسيا النهج التركي في السنوات
الماضيه ازعج الغرب بشكل كبير جدا تحديدا
الولايات المتحده والولايات المتحده يعني
تعلن عن هذا الامر بصراحه والتصريحات خلال
الحملات الانتخابيه في تركيا ايضا تعطي
هذا المعنى وتظهر بان الغرب اليوم يدعم
المعارضه التركيه في محاوله لاحداث تغيير
في في تركيا والتغيير في تركيا هو تغيير
ممكن ان يكون كبير جدا في المنطقه يحدث
تحولا كبيرا جدا
وهذا الامر بالنسبه للغرب امر امر مطلوب
فقط لافهم من حضرتك هل تشير هل تشير دكتور
بان الغرب يدعم فكره ان تفوز المعارضه
ام نتحدث عن ترابط تحدث عنه اردوغان ووصفه
بالخيانه
يعني اذا كان كنا نتحدث عن
دعم غربي للمعارضه التركيه بشكل مباشر
لا اعتقد ذلك لكن لا شك ان المعارضه
التركيه ان فازت في هذه الانتخابات ستكون
لديها علاقه افضل بالمنظومه الغربيه
ابتداء وبحلف الناتو ثانيا وبالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ثالثا او
ثالثا او ثانيا واولا وبالتالي انا اعتقد
ان من المؤكد ان علاقه الاتحاد الاوروبي
بشكل عام
والاستحقاقات التي كانت تنتظر تركيا امام
الاتحاد الاوروبي والكثير من الاتفاقيات
التركيه الاوروبيه التي تعتبر الان معطله
من المؤكد انها سيتم احيائها بشكل عام حتى
عندما ننظر يعني الى سياسه حزب العداله
والتنميه في سنواته الاولى كان يرفع شعار
الالتحاق بالاتحاد الاوروبي وتنظيم
وتنظيم الامور بالمعايير الاوروبيه بشكل
دائم الامر الذي جعل تركيا حقيقه في مصاف
الدول المتقدمه لانها اخذت بهذه المعايير
الاوروبيه اعتقد اليوم خطاب المعارضه لا
يختلف كثيرا عن خطاب حزب العداله والتنميه
في عام 2022 وما بعد لكن هناك تحولات قد
حصلت في السياسه الداخليه التركيه
والخارجيه التركيه
والعوده الى تلك السياسات من المؤكد انها
ستجلب الكثير من الايجابيات لتركيا
والاستثمارات ايضا الاوروبيه لتركيا
وكذلك
العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
نعم تحدثت عن علاقه تركيا وقلت بانه
المعارضه قادره ان تحسن اكثر من هذه
العلاقه سيد طه هل تعتقد بانه زمن اردوغان
قد انتهى من حيث هذه الجزئيات يعني بانه
انتهت حلول حز ب العداله والتنميه انتهت
حلول رئيس اردوغان لمحاوله تسيير امور
تركيا في ملفها مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او علاقات هذه او في ملفات اخرى
هل تتفق مع الاستاذ زاهد
لا لا اتفق تماما يعني البيت المتحده
الامريكيه نعم يعني قبل اعمال هي تحدثت
بكل وضوح وبكل صراحه هي تريد الاطاحه
بالرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان كما ذكر ضيفك من
باريس هناك سياسه تركيه مختلفه مستقله عن
سياسه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على عكس
السياسات التي انتهجتها الحكومات السابقه
في قبل عقود من الان ولكن نحن نتحدث عن
دوله كتركيا هناك الناخبه التركي هو الذي
يقرر سوف يحكم اردوغان ام كريشلار اشرت لك
حتى هذه اللحظه بان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان ما زال هو يحظى يعني بدعم شريحه
كبيره من الشارع التركي
بانه العلاقات صارت ابرد في السنوات
الاخيره مع واشنطن في فتره من الفترات
وكانه شبه قطيع مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
اردوغان طالما كان يهدد اوروبا بموضوع
اللاجئين
الذي قرا بان حلول اردوغان لتسيير شؤون
تركيا قد يعني انهارت شيئا ما
ما رايك حاليا سيدتي
كريمه حاليا هناك نلاحظ ان دول عديده في
المنطقه هي حولت الى الشرق كروسيا وكالصين
لم هي الدوله الوحيده التي يعني تبقى نعم
تركيا منذ سنوات علاقتها جيده
سياسيه وعسكريه والى حتى هذه اللحظه
التركي يعني هي لم تتخلى وتؤكد دائما
بانها هي عضو اساس ومهم في حلف الناتو
وعلاقتها معلومات المتحده الامريكيه لكن
السياسه التركيه الاخيره الخارجيه اصبحت
سياسه متعدد الابعاد هي تبحث عن مصالحها
هناك لها مصلحه مع روسيا نتحدث ان هناك
تحالف كبير تركي مع روسيا هناك تحالف فقط
مصلحه واضطراري او تكتيكه ان صح التعبير
في ساحات مختلفه تتحدث نتحدث عن ازمه
سوريه تركيا هي منخرطه هي وروسيا متربعه
على الارض السوريه في ليبيا في مناطق اخرى
في البلقانزه كان يجدر او يحتم على ان
تتواصل وانت تتعاون مع روسيا وهذا اغضب
الامريكيه
في خصوص هذا الموضوع بالتحديد وهو سؤال لك
دكتور محمد
تحدثت عن موضوع سوريا في الواقع البعض قال
بان الملف السوري محاوله التقارب مع
الجانب المصري محاوله يعني التراجع في
اللغه الحاده فيما يخص موضوع اللاجئين
كلها كانت ملفات استخدمها اردوغان ليس
لقناعه بها وانما لانه استخدمها لهذه
الانتخابات وهنا سؤال دكتور محمد هل تعتقد
بانه اذا فاز اردوغان سيتراجع عن كل هذه
الوعود
نعم هناك ضرورات يعني افضت الى ان يتخذ
الرئيس اردوغان هذه المواقف هو يريد اراحه
نفسه بعد الضغوط الكبيره التي تعرض لها في
السنوات الاخيره هو بالمناسبه يحمل
الولايات المتحده مسؤوليه محاوله الانقلاب
في عام 2016 وهو يتعرض لضغوط خارجيه على
الداخل التركي والى مطالب من الغرب بشكل
كبير جدا هذه اذا صح تسميتها بالتنازلات
هي هي تعبر عن حاجه الرئيس التركي وتركيا
بشكل عام الى ايجاد منافذ لدور سياسي جديد
والى التاقلم مع دوره جديد وهي في الوقت
نفسه تشعر بانها تتعرض لضغوط من الغرب
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور محمد سيف الدين
الباحث في العلاقه الدوليه من باريس الشكر
كذلك لضيوفي من اسطنبول زائد جيروس تحرير
انتبندن تركيا وطه الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
وسنبقى في انتظار النتائج او الاعلان عن
النتائج النهائيه للانتخابات التركيه
السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات